okay hello everyone thank you for tuning
in today to view my presentation and I'd
like to thank Bob roots for the
opportunity to present my work and I'm
really excited to be a part of this
online conference it seemed quite
exciting and there are a lot of great
presentations set up so I'm going to
take you through the research that I've
been doing in the lab so my name is
Rachel Lackey and I'm a PhD candidate at
the University of Western Ontario and I
work in the laboratory of dr. Markham
Vanya Prada that robots Research
Institute so the project I'm going to be
talking to you about today is looking at
a particular protein and it's a sort of
involvement in brain cell resilience or
survival during aging so the title of my
talk today is investigating the rules of
the hsp90 eco chaperone STI one in
neuronal resilience during aging so
first off what is stress and youthful
phosphoprotein one so since it's a bit
of a mouthful keep it down to calling it
STI one so SJ one is approaching that is
kind of referred to as sort of a
moonlighting protein so it has two
double functions respective to its
location in regards to the cell so
inside the cell it is known as a KU
chaperone so basically what this means
is it helps out a particular chaperone
proteins that are important for protein
quality control and making a immature
peptide into a functional protein so
sta-1 was I originally identified our
force function as a co chaperone in
yeast and that it particularly is
elevated in M cells that are under
different conditions of cellular stress
so there are different domains of STI 1
that interact with these chaperones and
basically the simple protein that
coordinates the functions of these
proteins now SJ 1 can also have very
different activities outside of the cell
so here it interacts with this eyelid
prion protein and this has a number of
beneficial effects for the cell which
I'll get into in to the next slide so
basically recently our lab developed
an STI one knockout line as most of the
literature up into this point regarding
STI 1 has been done in yeast or C
elegans worm models so our lab deleted
STI 1 in mice and it was found that this
was embryonic lethal and basically it
was alluding to the fact that STI 1 is
really important for development and
survival and interestingly there is
about 98% sequence homology between
mouse and human SK 1 so then we looked
at some human data sets and it was also
revealed that loss of function mutations
in STI when are not tolerated so this is
really highlighting the fact that STI 1
is really important for mammalian
function and mammalian survival and
basically for life soon as to further
elaborate upon as Taiwan's functions so
like I mentioned STI 1 um can be
secreted by cells different types of
glial cells or it's also expressed all
throughout the body
so basically STI one interacts with
cellular prion protein here it's denoted
as being PR PC and STI one highlighted
sort of an orange and basically extra
cellular interaction leads to a number
of neuro trophic signal effects via
calcium signaling and basically some
examples of this are increased sorry
increased cell proliferation and
neuronal differentiation protein
synthesis all basically good things for
cells and then like I mentioned inside
of the cell SJ one was really critical
for the Coordination of hsp70 and 90 so
alone these proteins cannot interact
with each other it just be 70 and 90 so
you need STI 1 to allow for these
proteins to physically interact so STI 1
here being shown in pink hsp90 and green
and hsp70 for HSC 70 in blue and
basically STI 1 is just acting as a
client recruiter so it allows the client
that is currently being bound by hsp70
to transfer to hsp90 so this immature
sort of client or protein as I'm
referring to it as
than be folded through this machinery
into a functional protein so as I
mentioned deleting STI 1 and mice was
embryonic lethal and essentially what
our lab had shown with these mice is
that basically not having STI 1 really
my cell is unhappy you've had higher
amounts of cell death and this micro-ct
analysis here in the top right panel is
showing that you have improper
development of these embryos which is
essentially what's leading to death and
interestingly when we took tissue from
these embryos things that we saw a
decrease in the protein expression of a
number of hsp90 client proteins so all
in all not having sj1 really stresses
out cells and you need STI one for
viability in life so me being a
neuroscientist sort of my interest was
so what is really the functions for SJ
everyone bring her how important is it
because a lot of this work up until this
point has been done either in vitro
looking at neuron cultures or most of
the work being done in yeast so here in
this image here I was taken from the
Allen Brain atlas for an in situ
hybridization for STI 1 so basically you
can see within the brain it's really
highly expressed particularly in neurons
but you see it's really highly expressed
in that hippocampus the cortex so and so
and as I mentioned a lot of work about
STI when up until this point has been
done Pedro so as I mentioned sj1 can be
secreted and the glial cells within the
brain are known to secrete str1 such as
astrocytes and microglia and as this
secreted STI one that is really
important for keeping Browns viable and
actually protecting them against a
number of different cellular insults
such as different chemical stressors
environmental stressors even protein
aggregates having more sji one or I stay
one in the extracellular media really
protects and reduces the amount of cell
death and then finally more so looking
at the clinical literature it was shown
that mothers of children with autism
actually have higher levels of
antibodies against STI one so then this
group here
basically treated rodents with Auto
antibodies against SG Iowa and other
markers that were predicted to be
involved in autism and really this led
to a lot of changes in our development
of the of these rodents so changes in
brain volume and cell proliferation but
really contributed to the developmental
delay that you see in autism so as I
mentioned several times up into this
point a lot of work has just been done
in vitro with regards to ask yet one so
we want to know what's going on in vivo
in the brain particularly during aging
when neurons are really vulnerable so
this is our main hypothesis for this
work
they'll be presenting today so basically
we hypothesize that normal expression of
asking one is necessary for neuronal
resilience in vivo so as I mentioned the
problem that we've had up into this
point is that knock out for STI one is
embryonic lethal so this was really at
this point halted our ability to study
STI 1 in vivo since getting rid of it is
lethal so what we did was we generated a
hypo morphic allele mousseline is what
we call it and basically we're
discussing career loxp recombination to
delete a part of STI 1 so here we're
deleting exons 2 & 3 and just this
schematic here so this is just normal
full-length STI one gene mRNA and
protein and basically what we did was we
deleted exons 2 & 3 sorry which
corresponded to a deletion of the
n-terminal cpr when me and this domain
has been suggested to be redundant
within the literature as this domain TPR
1 interacts with hsp70 but does TP A to
B so basically this deletion is we're
truncating the protein were deleting the
secret one domain but because of this
deletion it led to the generation of a
new initiation codon which turned out to
be quite inefficient so taking a brain
tissue from these mice we see there was
a super
reduction in SEO and protein levels so
just as Western blot here showing
wild-type so just normal controls head
meaning heterozygous mutant so meaning
they're heterozygous for this for this
allele and then Delta TP is referring to
our homozygous mutant so both lacking
this TP are one domain so essentially
what we're seeing is these homozygous
mutants about an 80 percent reduction in
protein levels and then a corresponding
decrease in protein molecular weight
since we are deleting a domain so
interestingly despite reducing SJ 1
protein levels by about 80 percent these
mice do survive which is great so we
could further characterize them and
further study the roles vest here and
brain of living adult mice so basically
things that we were noticing off the bat
with this mouse model was that the
survival earlier on in life so just
being just after being born there's
there was about a 15% amount of these
homozygous mice being born so it was
particularly or was normal Mendelian
frequency you would expect 25% but we
were getting about 15% of these
homozygous mutants and one thing that we
particularly notice about these
homozygous mutant is that they're a lot
smaller and leaner than their
heterozygous and wild-type littermates
so it was just that these mice were
smaller and there's competition amongst
pups which is what was leading to death
early on in life as you see that their
survival as they get older is pretty
much just stays the same and flat as you
see in wild-type and heterozygous
mutants
so other phenotypic characterization of
these mice revealed that they're
actually metabolically hyperactive mmm
we have increased oxygen consumption and
co2 production in both the light and
dark cycles and then this was also
corresponding to increase locomotor
activity but other than these findings
being leaner and being metabolically
hyperactive
there were no gross phenotypes or health
problems with these mice so this allowed
us to further study sta-1 in vivo so as
I mentioned Sdn one is really critical
for the coordination of an immature
client between hsp70 and 90 so we wanted
to see if there are any consequences of
reducing STI one on this machinery so
this is just a schematic showing how STI
1 is involved in the chaperone cycle in
bring client and then just a number of
other Co chaperones and accessory
proteins that are involved in this
machinery that we also will look at so
first off by reducing STI levels by 80%
we saw that this had no effect on the
amount of mRNA approaching unipi hsp70
or hsp90
we also ended up finding which i will
will show below is that there was a
reduced expression of a subset of hsp90
accessory proteins or other immuno
fill-ins that were involved in protein
folding classical hsp90 core chaperone
which is AHA 1c dc37 p23 and FK BP 51
were not affected by reduce decimals but
as I mentioned we see a subset of it
just be 90 accessory proteins that were
reduced when s ji-hwan levels were also
significantly reduced
so again just showing wild-type
heterozygous and homozygous mutants
interesting lis we see a chip which is
actually a protein that is in
competition with STI one for the
interaction with hsp70 in the 90s TI one
promotes the folding of peptides or
unfolded proteins into functional
proteins whereas chip is more so it's an
e3 ubiquitin lies so it promotes the the
degradation of target protein so
interestingly we see that this chip
protein is reduced by about 50 percent
in both our heterozygous and homozygous
mutants and then other pivotal Pirlo
isomer
such as that pin 1 and SEPA were also
reduced in our heterozygous and
homozygous mutants so next we wanted to
investigate whether client proteins of
this hsp90 machinery were affected by
reduced levels of SGI 1 so a classical
client of this machinery is a steroid
hormone receptors our glucocorticoid
receptor is sort of the best studied and
we see again in our heterozygous and
homozygous sj1 mutants that there is a
significant reduction in the protein
levels glucocorticoid receptor they also
looked at other clients of this
machinery such as total tau in gr k2 and
again in both are heterozygous and
homozygous does she pre r1 s Jo and
mutants there is a significant reduction
in in levels of these proteins so
basically this interesting finding of
both heterozygous and homozygous mutants
I'm having reduced expression is were
thinking that SK one could be acting in
a dominant negative effect so just
having one Mew didn't have the morphic
allele and is affecting the wild-type
allele and is really compromising as
Taiwan's activity so we wanted to
determine if the the findings of
disturbed hsp90 accessory proteins or
client proteins were due to deletion of
the t PR 1 domain or if it was due to
reduced levels of SGI one so using the
CRISPR cash 9 machinery or the CRISPR
cas9 technique we developed Vanessa
Tiahuanaco neuronal cell line using SM
56 cells and we looked at the same hsp90
accessory proteins and client proteins
and essentially we see the same findings
that having in this case no STI one you
have reduced expression of
clients such as the coracoid receptor
but that we also again are seeing reduce
expression of pin one chip and SEPA and
most importantly in the either the third
bar these graphs or the far side of the
Western blot that you see when we read
transfect in STI one that this rescue is
the reduction in these clients or
accessory proteins so this is really
showing that our mouth line and is
basically an STI one loss of function so
taking all of this pretty stasis work
all together we wanted to really know
what were the consequences of reduced
expression on the aging brain and mice
so after some preliminary work we
focused our analyses on the hippocampus
which is a brain region which is
particularly vulnerable in as the age or
different types of stressors so one
thing that we were noticing was some
structural differences within the
hippocampus of old mice so first we
characterized younger mice I should
mention that most of these Western loss
that I had just previously shown we're
done in aged mice mice being around 15
to 18 months of age but we saw similar
findings when we took tissue from
younger mice but here this data I'm
going to show here first we're showing
younger mice so we focused in on the ca3
region of hippocampus just for what i'm
showing here today because this is a sub
region of the hippocampus which is
particularly vulnerable as mice age and
in disease in our general diseases or as
stress and in young mice we see sort of
a thinning going on in our homozygous
delts te arawa mutants but nothing
nothing significant but when we look at
13 18 month-old sj1 mutant mice we see a
significant loss of neurons within this
ca3 region of the hippocampus which is
showing a consequence
having reduced us ji-hwan is really
affecting him the integrity or the
viability of these neurons so then we
wanted to take things sort of to a
larger scale and we collaborated with a
group the kids in Toronto and we gave
them fixed mouse brains from our sjo a
mutant mice and they performed biometric
analyses using seven Tesla MRI and
essentially just what this data is
showing here so the left panel being
wild-type vs. heterozygous estion
mutants and then on the right being
wild-type versus our delta T pron
homozygous mutants and the most striking
findings of course being in that
homozygous mutants were seeing an
increase in brain volume which was not
necessarily expected because we saw that
these is nice for smaller but if you
think back it was shown in the rodents
that had Auto antibodies against SGI one
that it did increase brain volume in
these mice so just sort of match with
the literature but interestingly mmm-my
strikingly see really a something
special about the campus so that when
you have less SGI one this is one of
really one of the only brain regions um
that had decreased volume across the
whole brain in these in these SGI on
mutants an interesting we saw increased
volume in the cerebellum and the brain
stem but for now just for the purpose of
this talk just gonna focus on the
hippocampus so because we did seven
Tesla MRI and we were able to with
different segmentation analyses actually
analyzed the volume particular subfields
of the hippocampus including the dentate
gyrus c a1 C a 3 all those different
layers within the hippocampus so
strikingly like I mentioned what we find
is that hippocampal volume is reduced in
our in our homozygous St on mutants but
it's particularly we see significant
loss
volume within the dentate gyrus of the
hippocampus and also a tendency for the
ca3 to be reduced so just just to
clarify all of these MRI analyses were
done in aged 14 months old Delta te
arawa control mice then being controlled
littermates of course so again we wanted
to know we're significantly reducing the
volume of the hippocampus and this brain
region is really important for of course
learning and memory so are there any
consequences for learning and memory
when we have reduced hippocampal volume
and reduced STI Juan so so within the
literature has been constantly shown
that damaged or reduced neurons within
the hippocampus in the ca3 region
affects spatial facial memory so just
just practically damaging this region
yet leads to spatial memory deficits and
then ice also been shown even within
Alzheimer's disease patients that
there's a particular loss of these
neurons so then what we did just as a
simple probe for learning a memory in
these mice was train them over four days
in a hole like a tank of water to learn
where a particular platform within sorry
this pool was and this platform is semi
opaque so they can't easily see it but
they learn to find it as there are
different spatial cues within a room so
over four days they're trained to find
this target or this platform and
particular things that we look at is if
they take how long it takes them over
those four days to find the platform the
distance traveled should LAT form and
they're sort of mean speed within the
pool as they're swimming so this is
referred to as the Morris water maze
task and
basically we do see as there's a
reduction in latency and distance we do
see that the mice learn over the four
days where the or the platform and so
what is referred to as the target
quadrant so that's four days of training
and then on the fifth day we put the
mice in the pool of water but there is
no longer a platform so basically this
is referred to as the probe trial and
essentially we're just assessing whether
or not the mice remember where the
platform or the platform is so this is
referred to as the target quadrant shown
in my little cartoon here and then we
also analyze the percent time spent in
the other quadrants perspective to the
target quadrant and despite seeing that
these mice learn how they actually
within the probe trial they have
deficits in reference spatial memory so
this is really showing that there is a
consequence of British hippocampal
volume and STI one on spatial memory so
just to summarize what I've shown you
here today is that we generated a hypo
morphic STI one allele Mouse which
allowed us to study the functions of
this protein in vivo and mice
particularly as they age and we saw that
there were a number of consequences
reduced STI one particularly that we see
reduced neuronal resilience as mice age
particularly in the hippocampus and this
contributed to a spatial memory deficit
and our findings that they reduced hsp90
accessory proteins and clients suggest
that I stairwell may be acting as a key
regulatory know would have the hsp90
machinery so some of our future
directions are trying to understand
whether or not its particular cell types
that are contributing to neuronal
resilience as mice age as str1 is
expressed highly and most most of cell
types but the issue of course with this
most line was that this was a global
knockout it was everyone
so we're trying to determine if its cell
autonomous or non cell autonomous
mechanisms so sj1 in neurons are
particularly maybe as tab when
astrocytes are other glial cells that is
important for neuronal resilience either
it was shown in vitro that it's the
secreted sta-1 by glial cells that keeps
neurons healthy so stay tuned for that
but for now this this ends my talk for
today so I would really like to thank my
lab there's there's a number of us as
you can see in this photo here I really
like to thank dr. marcoh Vanya dr. dr.
marcoh and dr. Vanya Prado my
supervisors for all their their help and
support throughout this project and all
the different funding agencies and of
course our collaborators dr. Jason lurch
and Lily from Somerset kids with their
MRI expertise and analyses and of course
their funding agencies and I really like
to thank again lab roots for this this
opportunity presented my work and I hope
you learned something about sj1 in the
brain and thanks thanks for tuning in